[Music]
that is London
[Music]
close your eyes
see with mine
[Music]
you are a top student but look at you
now you can't keep using your father's
disappearance as an excuse to act out is
that his work well what's it about their
dad he wanted to touch the Stars imagine
that the aunt here wants to get to her
other hand as quickest option is to walk
across the street but it turns out a
straight line is not the shortest
distance between two points
not if you use fifth dimension it's
outside of the rules we know of time and
space the aunt arrives my hand
instantaneous so you follow space more
likely weren't going
[Music]
we heard a cry out in the universe we
believe he is and we're here to help you
find it we are in search of warriors
warriors who serve the good and the
light of the universe you're kidding
do I look like I'm kidding a little I'm
not I'm not your father's trapped by an
evil energy it's too strong for our
light and the only one who can stop it
is you be a warrior
my love is always there even if you
can't see
[Music]
trust me I trust you
[Music]
what's your name Laura sunny Croft Lara
your father's gone you could pick up
where he left off I see so much of him
in you
brilliant hello sprout if you're
listening to this then I must be dead
I found something a tool called the
mother of death if Trinity succeeds our
world is in danger promise me you will
stop me I promise I think I know where
my dad went that's right in the middle
of the devil sea it will be an adventure
death isn't hotter than Adventure
[Music]
[Music]
you shouldn't have come here but I'm
glad that you did
[Music]
what do you know about my father now I
see the lightness the recklessness close
the to once and for the fate of humanity
is now in your hands
[Music]
don't be too careful these days
the world has gone bloody mad I'll take
two
good afternoon massage as you know
parole and a privilege it's a mistake
but it happened and if I were to be
released I would um I would just want
the simple life I just want to hold down
a job make some friends you know pay my
bills even if this was possible it made
20 people seven people why do you need
to do this cause that's what I'm gonna
how long would it take you to make seven
pieces of jewelry in five or six hours
how long if I told you didn't have to
live with your mother anymore it's me
the water flask wait what do you need a
less
which man named ball which real name
8-ball what if we could make all this go
away then purse as well sorry okay I
[Music]
mean with my family I told him coming in
garage finally tell you how big a job no
I'm out I take the job I'll be back
before you know they come with him
this is mommy's very special work trip
[Music]
in three and a half weeks the Met will
be hosting its annual ball we are going
to Robins not the ball itself the neck
of Daphne Kluger valued at over a
hundred million dollars revenge it's a
twofer do not run a job in a job
[Music]
user spiffed can't we just go to this do
we have to steal stop yes
[Music]
is it genetic or the whole family like
this
literally
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you have
[Music]
[Music]
where is my daughter
people whom just disappear
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
with my mouth
[Music]
[Applause]
wait so how many of us early
so uh what are you dating like an
accountant now Ellen ventriloquist stop
you love a dummy this is not why we're
here
I know why we're here
a rescue op save the dinosaurs from the
island that's about to explode what
could go wrong
blue is alive you raised her do these
animals deserve the same protections
given to other species or should they
just be left to die these creatures were
here before us
and if we're not careful
they're gonna be here after
you know me
[Music]
life cannot be contemned life breaks
free life finds away
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
it's weird you like hang out with
animals more than people yeah
well animals get me a rescue George
Feeny was 2 years old
George never would have survived on his
own he definitely trusts you last night
George was 7 feet away 500 pounds
George you okay buddy you're scared it's
okay this morning is nine feet pushing a
thousand what's happening to my friend
are you familiar with genetic editing
changes will be incredibly unpredictable
is he the only one oh you didn't know
about the 30-foot wolf hell of a day huh
science experiments falling from the sky
having George on that plane it's big
mistake
I think we'll be all right
let's go save the world
it's coming back to me
you have to evacuate Chicago George
didn't ask for this they're gonna put
them down
that's not happening
[Music]
there's something in the river
I was just thinking the only thing
that's missing right now is the giant
crocodile over the century the hotel has
been his life but next summer
[Music]
[Music]
oh you keep of a full-service spa yeah
so impressive it's like a hotel on the
water
okay thank you
oh no Bobby's gonna puke
[Music]
I have seen gods fly
I've seen men build weapons that I
couldn't even imagine I've seen aliens
drop from the sky yeah but I have never
seen anything like this
how much more you hiding
[Music]
yeah
[Music]
my son it is your time
you get to decide what kind of thing you
are going to be
don't please I never freeze
[Music]
shall we my respect
cuz we own
I waited my entire life for this the
world's gonna start over I'm a burn at
all
what happens now determines what happens
to the rest of the world
[Music]
my name is Wade watts my dad picked that
name because it sounded like a
superhero's alter-ego like Peter Parker
or Bruce Banner but he died when I was a
kid my mom too and I ended up here
sitting here my tiny corner of nowhere
there's nowhere left to go nowhere
except the Oasis
[Music]
a whole virtual universe
[Music]
people come to the Oasis for all the
things they can do
[Music]
they stay because of all the things they
can be can you feel this
yeah the only place that feels like I
mean anything
the Oasis was the brainchild of James
Halliday oh if you're watching this I'm
dead
I created a hidden-object an Easter egg
the first person to find the egg will
inherit half a trillion dollars and
total control of the Oasis itself
who is this possible and how the hell is
he winning find him just a game
I'm talking about absolute
life-and-death stuff the Oasis the
world's most important economic resource
it's nothing less than a war for control
of the future
welcome to the rebellion wait
[Music]
I only came here to escape
[Music]
but I found something much bigger than
just myself
are you willing to fight
helped us save the oasis
I have a dream
to see I'm so glad you're here
I'm pregnant but I don't know how to do
this by myself
your mother is the bravest person we
ever made good bye baby
let me tell you how she did it all on
her own
[Music]
why see short the world is wide
I want to make some memories
this dress might look very pretty on you
you don't know me at all do you
[Music]
I think we should stay here together
well I wish I could stay here too
turns out he's engaged I hate it when
they do that I was cheated by you I
think you know when look at me now will
I ever learn I don't know how but I
suddenly lose control there's a fire
within my soul never felt closer than my
mama she wasn't scared because she had
me
we can't tell anybody else about the
baby okay
I just told bill and I told Harry I told
many many people let's get the party
started grandma you weren't invited
that's the best kind of party little
girl
there was an idea to bring together a
group of remarkable people to see if we
could become something more so when they
needed us we could fight the battles
that they never could
[Music]
in time you will know what it's like to
lose feel so desperately that you're
right there to fail all the stack
read it
run so much
Dustin's still alive
[Music]
evacuate the city
and gates or defenses
and get this manna sheet
[Music]
[Music]
fun isn't something one considers from
balancing the universe
but this does put a smile on my face
[Music]
who the hell are you guys
[Music]
[Applause]
well look at you may your dreams bring
you peace in the darkness
this is just funny it's not bad or good
that part's up to you
I don't mean to be rude if I supposed to
know
actually me we just met
of
it's harsh world strong prey on the weak
down here
does it bother you that I'm not
completely human
whatever I had to you for you I'd give
you whatever I have
I'd give you my heart Alida
they will come for you
why
I think you're someone very special mais
de
[Music]
of the
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
take off your dress
when I was in Moscow I heard about a
program
young officers traitors juice and
manipulate
[Music]
to use your bodies
two's everything color sparrows that's
what she is
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Christmasy time mystery
[Music]
expectations
who knows what might happen
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
time has come
[Music]
[Music]
how would you define terrorism the
current definition is any individual or
group it uses violence to achieve
political goal
administration believes that the drug
cartels fit that definition
[Music]
you want to see this thing through I'm
gonna have to get dirty turning you
loose holders new rules this time the
earth
[Music]
[Music]
help us start a war with hope
[Music]
everyone
I'm gonna ask you a series of questions
I want you to respond truthfully have
you ever heard someone
yes have you ever experienced anything
you'd consider ignore me
yes
last question do you know a mutants are
did you know baby rattlesnakes are more
dangerous and adult once they haven't
learned how to control how much venom
they secrete
[Applause]
all of you are dangerous
that's why your year
[Applause]
[Music]
what is this place this is in the
hospital
[Applause]
you're being through hard get some rest
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we were born into a world at war between
the monsters that destroyed our cities
and the monsters we created to stop them
we thought we had sacrificed enough but
the wall we thought we finished is just
beginning and the only thing standing in
front of the apocalypse
is us
but it doesn't matter where you came
from who believed in you and who did it
this is our time this is our chance to
make a difference
let's get it done
No
drop
they evolved an egg-white life
[Music]
there's something you need to see
well he's pretty big
[Music]
by everything you got
[Music]
you
you